all right 2024 Republican presidential
candidate Vivek ramaswamy he called out
the left last week for its racist
rhetoric it didn't go over too well over
a fake news CNN take a look at that
tense interview what I said is the grand
wizards of the KKK would be proud of
what they would hear her say because
there's nothing more racist than saying
that your skin color predicts something
about the content you didn't just say
that you didn't just say they would be
proud you said these are the words of
the modern Grand wizards of the modern
KKK
it is the same Spirit you're right about
that Dana I think it is the same Spirit
to say that I can look at you and based
on just your skin color that I know
something about the content of your
character that I know something about
the content of the viewpoints you're
allowed to express for Ayanna Presley to
tell me that because of my skin color I
can't express My Views that is wrong it
is divisive that is driving hate that is
a debate this is divided that is a
debate Breaking Point
we don't need any more black faces that
don't want to stand up for the black
community something to that effect is
the comment he was responding to
Meanwhile after he went viral for
performing the Eminem song One Eminem
song on The Campaign Trail Vivek has now
been sent a cease and desist letter from
rapper Eminem I'm sure he's really
scared anyway in the NFL Hall of Fame
running back O.J Simpson appeared to
endorse Vivek this weekend saying the
guy really would have a chance anyway
2024 GOP candidate Vivek ramaswamy joins
us with reaction how are you sir
it's good to see you Sean how are you
good uh I think you've dealt with the
issue of of your battle with
congresswoman Presley a lot over the
weekend I don't think we need to rehash
whole ground I want to go over some of
the issues though you know you said Aid
to Israel our number one Ally Only
democracy in the region should end in
2028 and that they should be integrated
with their neighbors I have an exact
quote you want me to read it that's
actually
yeah you I can tell you the exact quote
what I said is it would be a mark of
success if we ever got to a point in our
relationship with Israel if Israel never
needed the United States as Aid and Sean
you know how politics is played a lot of
the other professional politicians who
have been threatened by my rise have
used that statement to say that I would
cut off Aid to Israel that's not correct
I've been crystal clear but do you the
only condition under which do you
understand the importance of the
Strategic Alliance the intelligence
sharing yes in an area of the world
where we have a lot of enemies which by
the way boggles my mind that we look for
uh the lifeblood of our economy and the
world's economy from that very same uh
region of the world and we have more
natural resources here which you agree
but you do understand how important that
Alliance is the intelligence I
understand how important it is with Iran
especially seeking nukes
I understand it I think more deeply than
probably anybody in this race I've
traveled to Israel I have business
partners in Israel the reality is this
by the end of my first term our
relationship with Israel will be
stronger than it ever has been because I
will treat it as a true friendship not
just a transactional religion why did
you say this preferential treatment why
did you say that Israel should not have
presidential treatment from us that's a
direct quote Sean I I understand no
those are direct quotes from headlines
summarized by opposition research fed to
the fake news media the reality is
here's what I'm saying that but Abraham
reports 2.0 is my top priority Abraham
according 2.0 is my top priority which
is to get Saudi Arabia Oman Qatar into
that pact with Israel and foremost to
have a partnership with Israel that does
something really important for the U.S
which is to make sure that Iran never
ever ever has nuclear capabilities
that's important to the United States
and the other thing I've said Sean is
that Israel is our friend good friends
learn from each other I would love
Israel's border policies in this country
I would love Israel's tough on crime
policies and strong national identity in
this country I would love an Iron Dome
like Israel has to defend itself against
Hamas which is a good thing for Israel I
want something like that here in the
United States so I don't read from the
traditional GOP talking point binder
that's handed to traditional candidates
that's true that lends itself to being
misquoted but it's actually a much more
authentic commitment to Israel on the
substance than just checking off the
talking point of saying that we stand
with Israel that's meaningless I prefer
substance and that's exactly where I've
gone in a lot of these long-form
podcasts I've done I know that most if
not most conservatives unfortunately I
see Vladimir Putin as evil a thug a
murderer and he's trying to fulfill his
territorial Ambitions I do believe we're
going to watch China at some point try
to fulfill their territorial Ambitions
with Taiwan in the case of Ukraine you
make a great point though I mean uh I at
a sovereign country was invaded this is
first and foremost a European problem
they have not stepped up to the degree
that was necessary to actually assist
them and protect their continent and Joe
Biden throw in billions and billions of
tax dollars but yet putting handcuffs on
the ukrainians and their ability to
fight the war denying them uh Poland
migs early on deny this is not a real
there's only a situation where I see
this becoming a quagmire because they
want it to be a quagmire now if you're
gonna if you're gonna engage if Europe
wants to engage and defeat Putin they've
got to fight the war to win the war
they've got to have the tools to fight
the war to win the war the first
responsibility should be Europe's if the
United States wants to help and Aid them
in their effort because they're
targeting innocent men women and
civilians at that point the U.S I think
is should be responsible for some help
but not the help that we've been giving
uh which which basically comes with no
responsibility or no plan to actually
win the conflict
well there's there's also a further
Point Sean which is that if we had been
energy independent in this country and
had been an exporter of energy Putin
would have never felt he had the
leverage to go after Ukraine but there's
a deeper strategic point now
Russian European allies all of their
energy needs and we'd be becoming an oil
exactly Rich energy and I've said that
countless times but yeah that's one of
the key lessons we have to learn is
energy Independence and energy security
is National Security but now Sean
there's also a deeper point which is
that I worry we are now driving Russia
closer into China's arms and the Russia
China Alliance is the single greatest
threat that we face and that's what I
really worry about
it's Russia China and Iran exactness of
evil is formed so the question is
in the and I want a week a week at a two
um and I'd love to see that happen all
right so what specifically the issue of
you and Taiwan until we have enough
microchips in 2028 what is your policy
if if China seeks to fulfill their
territorial Ambitions with Taiwan
so I'm the only presidential candidate
in either party who has had the courage
to say that I'm not going to embrace the
one China policy which is the posture of
both political parties today that I'm
not going to just adopt strategic
ambiguity we can't afford that we need
to be clear that we will defend Taiwan
that's different from strategic
ambiguity now we have to defend Taiwan
until we achieve semiconductor
Independence at which point we resume
our current posture of strategic
ambiguity which is exactly what the U.S
adopts today so Sean all right so let me
remind you right now the US's position
is a one China policy yeah let me ask
you this at what point for example if
Russia wanted to put nuclear weapons 90
miles south of our border in Cuba we did
have a Cuban Missile Crisis what would
your posture be there in other words if
you're saying as long as Taiwan said
against semiconductor chips uh will help
them but after that they're on their own
no I actually Sean and that's again how
my position's been caricatured I will
remind you and everybody else right now
the United States
I'm listening no it's not what I'm
saying because well I'll I'll give it to
you very simply right now the United
States's policy towards Taiwan is a one
China policy Donald Trump was derided he
was made fun of for daring to pick up a
phone call from the Taiwanese president
the United States of America right now
does not even recognize Taiwan as a
nation I view it differently I am clear
that we will defend Taiwan I'm the only
politician in either party that has the
iron 2028 and then I would resume well I
would resume the current position of the
United States after we've achieved
semiconductor Independence so that's the
hard truth Sean is nobody in either
party has the courage to actually say
taiwan's even a nation I do and that's
why we're going to defend afterwards
we'll resume our position of strategic
ambiguity which is the current status
quo I will remind you Sean so I think
that that level of clarity would make Xi
Jinping a fool to invade Taiwan before
we have semiconductor Independence and
it also helps Taiwan increase its own
military carry spending as a percentage
of GDP which is dangerously low today
and I think that that's the way that I
lead with American interests while
avoiding World War III ensuring that we
have true semiconductor Independence in
this country and deterring Chinese have
nailed down perfectly in my view is the
Strategic benefit of energy dominance
and that we could have we could have
bankrupted Putin as it relates to if we
were producing enough energy for Western
Europe uh similarly our other allies
around the world uh but you know going
back to this uh this idiotic policy of
energy dependence not only is it
resulting in higher prices for
everything every American buys every
place they go and now the higher prices
again at the pump uh it has this ripple
effect that impacts National Security
Economic Security and on that major
point which is if we did that we'd be
all better off you're dead right uh
Vivek good to see you thank you yes and
all right more bizarre climate protests
and Brazen crime the less liberal lunacy
a new low they just hit it we've got the
latest after this break
foreign